Let's do our makeup together
while I tell you a few facts about me.
Because there's so many new people on here.
So. Hi, everyone.
My full name is Nora Aziza Smith.
I was born on September 27th, 2,001.
So I'm 22 years old,
and I'm a Libra.
I was born in Bloemfontein,
South Africa.
My mom's South African and my dad's German.
And we moved to Germany
when I was about three months old.
Because I guess they wanted me to grow up in Germany.
I've lived in Freifor,
Germany, my entire life.
We never moved.
And I speak two languages.
English and German.
Dutch on English,
then vitamin and motosh.
Pothom. Then
as soon as I turned 18,
I moved to California,
even though I've never been before.
I'm the oldest of three siblings.
I have a younger sister who's 18,
and then I have a younger brother who's twenty.
I also have a half brother on my mom's side
who lives in South Africa.
When I was 14,
I got scouted by a modeling agency.
And I've been doing modeling ever since then.
That's also how I met my husband.
After six months of dating,
we got married
and then had two kids
and were pregnant with our third.
We have a daughter.
Her name is rumble.
And we have a son.
His name is slim.
My husband also has a daughter
from his previous relationship.
I've always wanted to be a young mom
because growing up,
my dad would
Always tell us that he regrets having kids
later in life.
So I took that advice,
and it's one of the best decisions I could have made,
and I know it's not for everyone.
I was always very mature and independent
and did a lot of things at a very young age.
So I never feel like I'm missing out on
any of the partying,
any of that,
because I've done all of that.
I grew up playing a lot of instruments,
from the saxophone
to the flute
to the piano,
but I ended up playing the piano for about eight years.
I think I also worked at a smoothie shop
while I was in high school.
I was just so slow
that no one really wanted to work with me,
so I got overwhelmed and quit.
I'm a very routine,
organized person,
so I do not do well if I'm not on a routine or.
When I finished high school,
my plan was to study marine biology,
but my plan shifted,
and now I'm cooking a lot more
and being on social media.
I know that my religion is a very hot topic
on the internet.
I don't know what I'm doing.
I'm still learning and figuring out my own faith.
I'm not in any way a hardcore Mormon
or anything like that.
I don't wear garments.
I didn't get married in the temple.
Both me and my husband are on our own journeys
and figuring out how we Want to raise our kids.
I've always loved cooking,
but I just recently,
in the past year,
have gotten really passionate about it.
It all started when I was dealing with
really severe eczema,
and I had to make sure that what I put in my body
would be good for my body.
And that's kind of how I got into nutrition
and food and cooking
also. My regular lip combo is MAC lip liner and Cork,
and then I either do
the benetint or the beneflora in the middle.
And then sometimes I do a gloss on top,
or I do the Brown Summer Fridays Dream lip oil.
I line my lips,
and then I go in with this.
I've also never gotten anything done to my face.
A lot of people think I've gotten lip filler,
which I have not.
And there we go.